more than 3 million Americans filed for
unemployment benefits the last week of
March that's more than quadruple the
previous record in the history of the
country yet in a matter of months
jobless figures like that 3 million
could look small by comparison
Goldman Sachs estimates that later this
year America's unemployment rate could
hit fifteen percent that would be the
highest figure since the 1930s that's
almost 25 million people out of work and
Goldman's estimate is not even the
highest one economists the st. Louis
branch the Federal Reserve Bank are
projecting an unemployment peak as high
as 32 percent that's 47 million people
out of work in case you're wondering
that is worse than the worst year of the
Great Depression much worse actually at
some point kernel virus will be gone but
unfortunately we could live with the
crushing unemployment numbers for far
longer and that's a disaster for people
for individuals for families but it's
also a threat to the stability of our
country nothing makes a nation more
volatile than huge numbers of people who
don't have jobs that's always true so we
need to do whatever we can to prevent
that from happening
but here's the amazing thing the federal
government is doing its best tonight to
make it much worse here's how today
April 1st the Department of Homeland
Security released 20,000 new h-2b visas
for seasonal guest workers to come into
America and take jobs in industries like
landscaping food processing and resorts
another 15,000 visas will become
available next month in May now these
are bonus visas by the way by law the
United States only has to offer 66,000
h-2b visas a year but Homeland Security
Secretary Chad Wolfe has used his
discretionary powers to add thirty-five
thousand extra visas so that's a total
of a hundred thousand workers coming to
this country to take jobs during the
single biggest unemployment crisis in a
century it's demented and yet it gets
worse than that
yesterday DHS notified 85,000 new
winners of the h-1b visa lottery today
those winners can begin filling out
their full visa applications for jobs
that will begin in in October October
hmm that's just when unemployment could
be at its peak and coronavirus could be
making a comeback as the weather cools
those are the forecasts h-1b visas are
supposed to allow companies to
I are foreigners with extraordinary
skills that simply don't exist in the
American workforce it's a fraud of
course a well-documented fraud in
practice the visas are used to import
tens of thousands of tech workers from
India so Silicon Valley can profit from
a cheaper workforce nothing is the
workers but they're taking jobs that
would go to Americans the big winners in
this scheme are companies like Apple
Google and IBM was taken hundreds of
h-1b workers every year at many
companies including AT&T as we Chronicle
recently on this show American workers
are ordered to train their foreign
replacements and then fired once they're
no longer useful this has been going on
for a long time it's always been
disgusting but now it's a threat to our
country
and that's not an overstatement in a
year work tens of millions of Americans
could be looking for work our government
is importing more than a hundred and
fifty thousand workers from abroad and
that's without counting thousands of
h-2a agricultural workers who will be
coming as well the president needs to
stop this from happening and he can if
President Obama was able to ignore
existing immigration law and create daca
and he did then certainly the current
president has the power to cut legal
immigration in order to protect the
nation and in fact American law gives
him explicitly this right here it is
this is from section 1182 F of title 8
in the u.s. code quote whenever the
president finds that the entry of any
aliens or of any class of aliens into
the United States would be detrimental
to the interests of the United States
he made a proclamation and for such
period as he shall deem necessary
suspend the entry of all aliens or any
class of aliens as immigrants are not
immigrants or impose on the entry of
aliens any restrictions he made em
appropriate and quote it's very clear
and the Supreme Court just affirmed this
law two years ago in the case the
president's travel ban so it's real now
that ban you'll remember was levied to
protect Americans from terrorism but now
we're facing an immeasurably greater
crisis than terrorism we're facing a
global calamity to fit wrecked our
economy fracture our society because
that's always a byproduct of it erode
our rights shatter our institutions
transform this country into a poor
country a has-been X superpower beholden
to China that could happen preventing
that from happening is the most
important test this president or any
president in our lifetime will face the
time to placate corporate interest
looking for low wages at all costs has
passed we need to stop this